dick and lace explains Greece's
privatization trust fund rather bluntly
what evers not absolutely necessary can
be sold off and the proceeds used to
save what's left that's his approach to
reorganizing bankrupt companies Madsen
is in for my at least the same pain is
unavoidable there's a reason the
company's in crisis and if they want to
get out again that means cuts for all
concerned what goes for bankrupt
companies also applies to bankrupt
states so Greece's creditors are
demanding that the country sell off
state assets stakes in banks ports
airports and railways the European
lenders anticipate the fund will raise
upwards of 50 billion euros but um
places afraid public assets will end up
being sold far undervalue York support
sean is yoga the pressure here is no
secret everyone who tenders a bid in the
privatization process knows that so of
course the bidders the private companies
will try to take advantage of that
pressure the privatization strategy is
not new to Greece
the sea port of piraeus is partly owned
by china's costco group now the rest of
it is up for sale as well Greek airports
could also be under foreign management
soon last autumn Fraport the operator of
Frankfurt Airport had almost finalized a
deal until Greece's new left-wing
government stopped it
it was trying to prevent a sell out of
the country and a wholesale loss of
Greek jobs privatization doesn't
automatically mean everything's going to
be more expensive and the quality worse
it can also mean greater product
diversity and improved conditions for
the citizens above amended estaras the
deal for C's half of the proceeds going
to the banks so that people can again
access their accounts another 12 billion
are earmarked as investments to
stimulate the economy when dirt and less
reorganizes a company he does it with a
well-considered plan that's missing here
one is an yours plan without a plan of
reorganization I think it's doomed to
fail there's no vision of what Greece is
supposed to look like 10 or 15 years
from now in 10-15 yarn alize enjoyed
what vision there is calls for more
efficient financial structures and a
fundamental change of attitude but these
can't be bought with money from any fund